o fim da equipe passou a se chamar
chorei
nossos desafios as nossas lutas e a
nossa vivência no hip hop enquanto o
coletivo família de rua o coletivo que
eu faço parte e ao coletivo que realiza
há sete anos em belo horizonte o duelo
de amicis começa em agosto de 2007 e
agosto de 2007 um grupo de amigos é
decide e do espaço público para a praça
da estação em belo horizonte e realizar
uma batalha de misses encontro de hip
hop em bh
naquela época na rua já não acontecia
mais só nos espaços privados e
principalmente em boates
durante a noite aquele espaço de
convivência da juventude na rua naquela
época já não acontecia
nós passamos a em 2007 nos reunir no
espaço público para realizar uma batalha
de mcs que aos poucos foi foi se
tornando uma celebração da cultura hip
hop cultura hip hop modo de vida da
rapaziada da moçada do bairro bronx's da
década de 70 eo hip hop tem algumas
manifestações artísticas que são as suas
manifestações principais e que são
manifestações principalmente da
juventude
essa juventude é uma parcela da
juventude que começou a organizar o
duelo de misses
essa foi a nossa primeira bandeira nosso
primeiro banner feito à mão pra mostrar
um pouquinho do que era e é isso e vices
no espaço público fazendo um encontro e
esse encontro se torna o encontro de
todas as manifestações do hip hop o zé
misses os djs os grafiteiros dançarinos
e dançarinas ocupando depois da praça da
estação com a época da chuva o viaduto
santa tereza quem é que conhece o
viaduto santa tereza
parte de cima ou a parte de baixo as
duas
o cartão postal de belo horizonte a
parte de cima mas na parte de baixo a um
espaço próprio e propício para a cultura
ea arte que é chamado arco das artes e
foi instituído por volta do ano 2000
esse espaço que vocês estão vendo ali
agora que com os anos foi sendo
modificado pela ocupação do duelo e de
outros grupos culturais
e hoje está todo grafitado tá todo nosso
estilo a todo nosso naipe
afinal de contas quem mais conviveu ele
tem sido agente do hip hop e aí pra
vocês terem uma idéia do que acontece
ali
vamos passando a ocupação tem crescido e
essa é uma imagem do duelo de mc's
nacional que a gente realizou em 2012 e
completamente lotado cerca de 2500
pessoas debaixo de um viaduto curtindo
cultura hip hop
bora bora batalha de mcs é o carro chefe
mas tem também de jazz tem também a
dança o grafite
nesse caso a gente sempre acreditou nele
as pilastras do viaduto e as rodas de
dança são uma constante
nesse encontro porém não obstante a
partir de um dado momento nós começamos
a travar duelos para realizar o duelo
nós tivemos o nosso primeiro duelo no
primeiro dia de realizar o primeiro
duelo
ao chegar na praça da estação ao reunir
dez pessoas na praça da estação fomos
interpelados pela guarda municipal e
questionado se nós tínhamos alvará para
estar na praça da estação 10 pessoas sem
caixa de som sem equipamento de som e
microfone fazendo o clima improvisada
não poderíamos estar na praça da estação
fazendo improvisada em dez pessoas
fomos jogados pela frente domingo ele e
aí nós ficamos até o final de 2007 2008
a gente vai para o viaduto santa tereza
na época das chuvas
descobre o melhor espaço de belo
horizonte para o hip hop e lá começamos
a ocupar mas preocupar
a gente descobriu que
tem uma série de dificuldades e
burocracias pra gente fazer qualquer
coisa na rua você tem que ter limpeza
você tem que ter um banheiro químico
você tem que ter ações do juizado para
ver como é que os menores estão naquele
espaço 70 energia elétrica
você tem que ter policiamento preventivo
alguma coisa dessas funciona
bom vamos lá para poder funcionar
a família de rua o tempo inteiro
estabeleceu um caminho de diálogo sim
somos do hip hop sim somos rua sim a
gente é meio marrento fato nós
a gente não é burro que a gente entende
que com diálogo as coisas são
construídas
porém mesmo com um número infindável de
reuniões que nós tivemos e ainda temos o
estado
e aí quando eu falo estado município e
governo do estado não cumprem aquilo que
em reunião em alta em ata é acordado com
o coletivo de jovens organizados e aí as
dificuldades tendem sempre a crescer e
foram crescendo na realização do duelo
de mcs ano após ano desde 2007
embora a principal dificuldade nossa
talvez seja a polícia militar segurança
primeiro a gente se pergunta se a gente
quer
a polícia militar por perto com todo
respeito aos policiais militares
mas a gente se pergunta se a gente quer
em um dado momento a situação do duelo
vai ficando critica o número de público
vai aumentando afinal de contas vivemos
numa sociedade numa cidade que não
proporciona o impulso para as pessoas os
jovens principalmente se encontrarem no
espaço público e quando tem o que
acontece em geral que descer geral de
todas as periferias da cidade de todas
as quebradas da cidade da região
metropolitana é interessante para o
estado ter essas pessoas na rua
reunidas unidas fortes
sei não e aí rapaziada moçada
em 2010 2011
por duas vezes a gente é interpelado de
formas diferentes em 2010
a polícia militar faz uma primeira ação
no viaduto santa tereza no dia 3 de 19
em que a polícia militar sem informar os
organizadores do duelo de misses fecham
a parte de baixo do viaduto santa tereza
com viaturas gomes do juizado e tv
record revistam todo mundo não deixam
ninguém entrar e sair
durante a ação a um momento em que há
uma pessoa que toma tiro é levada não
nos é dada explicação nós fomos
abordados enquanto organizadores no
final do duelo
fomos revistados de forma arbitrária
afinal hora nenhuma
mostramos nenhum tipo de reação
agressiva
muito pelo contrário estabelecemos um
diálogo para entender o que estava
acontecendo há alguns meses depois é nós
fomos chamados aliás alguns meses
anterior no mesmo meses anteriores nós
havíamos sido chamados para uma reunião
em que a polícia militar eo pedido era
da polícia militar da prefeitura de belo
horizonte da regional centro sul fizeram
a seguinte colocação ao sentar nessa
reunião que foi essa reunião ele
simplesmente disseram o duelo vai parar
o duelo acabou e quando eu pergunto
porque é insustentável
não dá do jeito que tá acontecendo vocês
estão muito desorganizados
não dá pra continuar o duelo a gente não
entende isso enfim sempre dialogamos
sempre conversamos ea coisa nunca mudou
em 2011
da mesma forma um ano depois
literalmente 39 de 2010 29 de 2011
a polêmica polícia militar junto com o
juizado e dessa vez junto com a record
faz a mesma ação no viaduto santa tereza
sem nos informar sendo muito agressivos
dessa vez chegando a puxar cabo do som
apontar a arma pra mim apontar a arma
para outros organizadores sendo que o
tempo inteiro a gente estava ali
tentando
jogar nesse quadro de abandono da
polícia militar do espaço e depois do
abandono elas vir cobrar da família de
rua uma organização maior melhor que
eles não participavam fazendo o
policiamento preventivo nós fizemos um
dossiê mostrando todas essas falhas
fizemos uma série de reuniões em 2012
que por incrível que pareça não deram em
nada novamente reunidos guarda municipal
belotur
reunimos o governo do estado em várias
áreas do governo do município e nada
mudou em relação ao duelo
nenhum desses órgãos atualmente de forma
preventiva e da forma que deveriam no
duelo
e esse não atuar foi gerando um ambiente
o duelo pode mudar por favor que foi um
ambiente do insustentável
esse ambiente do insustentável que é
graças à omissão da pm omissão da
polícia militar gerou uso excessivo de
drogas o tráfico de drogas excessivo e
algumas situações inclusive de ameaça de
homicídio
por mais que a família de rua no teste
até com a rapaziada tentasse puxar
rapaziada para a consciência ausência do
estado
mesmo com todo o diálogo da família de
rua gerou uma situação onde 2013 em
junho a gente decide parar o duelo de
mcs plano de miska essa época já era
considerado um dos maiores encontros da
cultura hip hop do brasil nós durante
sete anos
ocupamos um espaço público
insistentemente tentando fazer com que a
juventude de periferia organizada
tivesse voz local
nessa cidade isso nunca foi suficiente
para que o estado fizesse a sua parte e
nós o tempo inteiro como os culpados
pelos erros que não eram nossos
afinal de conta geral da família de
rolar do trabalho
largou tudo tá vivendo no pv emg de
grano perrengue de tudo para poder
sustentar os projetos da família de rua
mas a gente é culpado afinal a gente é
desorganizado mas será que é por que a
gente é jovem
ela é muito organizado não sabe muito
bem o que quer
eu fico me perguntando se não é isso
porém a coisa piora pode piorar
sempre pode a reforma do viaduto começa
no início desse ano e começa de uma
forma que sinceramente só traz
dificuldades e problemas já sabe já
sabíamos que essa reforma mais hora
menos hora aconteceria à final desde
2010 vem sendo anunciada essa reforma
primeiro via pac das cidades históricas
em 2012 depois via uma empresa que devia
município e agora em 2013 é a informação
de que aconteceria assim com verba do
governo do estado
porém essa reforma começa agora em 2014
sem que os grupos que ocupam um espaço
fossem informados anteriormente e sem um
diálogo devido com esses grupos para que
possamos pensar de fato e conjuntamente
o projeto de reforma e qual é o projeto
de gestão pós reforma já impossível
projeto de gestão que não tenha
participação popular nesse projeto de
gestão e ainda assim acreditam na
execução dessa reforma dessa retórica
revitalização mas diante desse quadro o
que acontece é o início de 2014
com a reforma a gente permanece uma
semana ocupando o viaduto e exigindo
essas informações alguma nós conseguimos
algumas outras infelizmente não mas
continuamos na luta para poder descobrir
a melhor forma de estabelecer esse ponto
onde a sociedade civil juventude
organizada tem parte no processo que diz
respeito a ela
não há outros independente de tudo o
duelo de mc's livre no meu coração na
minha alma na nossa alma do nosso
imaginário e no nosso dia a dia e vive
por causa dessas coisas e ó segundo esse
rapaz aí meu amigo de salvador talpa
sítio o duelo de pesquisa maior
concentração de abraços por
o quadrado ele veio e 2012 e 2013 para o
viaduto santa tereza pra ver o duelo de
mc's nacional e largou essa eu chorei na
hora admito eu sou meio desses que chora
mesmo é normal apesar da barra e é isso
como v
e é isso ora passar abraço tempo inteiro
rapaziada mostrado é isso aí abraço por
abraços sorrisos
é uma frase que eu faço uma música
tocando corações e gerados sorrisos
isso é hip hop ec juventude e cultura e
arte para sorriso sorriso pra geral a
gente precisa sorrir na vida e é o que a
gente vê no viaduto
a gente vê família somos família de rua
enquanto família e cantar mesmo com o
moleque que é filho do meu amigo num
viaduto e moleque tá lá viaduto no
espaço sujo não é um espaço degradado
não a degradação depende da forma como
você vê que a gente viu ali
possibilidade de vida e vida familiar
bora lá aí o porquê não famílias
reunidas unidas juntas debaixo do
viaduto
falei ah isso falou no falou bora
douglas nascimento do gradim
duas vezes campeão do duelo é preciso
nacional o morador da serra
moleque daqui hoje é considerado um dos
maiores improvisadores do brasil e
começou o seu trabalho desenvolver o seu
trabalho debaixo de um viaduto onde
ninguém botar o pé onde todo mundo evita
de passar mas esse viaduto foi motor
para o sonho de moleque hoje de 23 anos
que está lutando para viver de hip hop
dever do talento dele quer ser vice
agora a rapaziada que já passou e pode
passar o rap hood bruno melhor de belém
emicida são paulo e muita gente deve
conhecer marechal e é isso rapaziada
isso que acontece debaixo do viaduto é
celebração e celebração de vida mesmo
a celebração da juventude que quer estar
na cidade quer ocupar a cidade ter
direito à sua cidade
o nosso engajamento é estar no palco do
espaço público sendo quem a gente é
sendo hip hop sendo skate do punk hip
sendo quem a gente quer ser não o que o
sistema projeta pra gente pra terminar
em clima de celebração nada melhor que
fazer que o que a gente faz no viaduto e
para acompanhar os amigos do chá eo
certo
ei
o shopping lotte situação
é o seguinte a nossa cultura começa com
a cultura dos crioulos daqueles e
daquelas que contam histórias através do
conhecimento e à poesia
ela é equipada é improvisada na hora é
criada
e olha só na questão de aparência plano
deve se encerrado
símbolo de resistência da resistência
promovido pela juventude juventude que
pra muitos anos ea tia ruth um sabe o
que quer
alguns olham namur homem chamou de
vagabundo ou me chamo de recolher à
barra mansa às vezes com a cara fechada
porque a situação pra nós parceiro o
casal engraçada complicada foi cassada
embaçado obrigado jerusalém gado é bom
ligar o desconfiômetro eu
só pelo cronômetro amor ao flamengo no
treinamento do bope por uma coisa
chamada sentimento o que eu sinto no dia
a dia o que me move é isso
a música arte uma moto e provoque fotos
no meio da rua
tem gente que fica meio puto porque deus
moleque ocupando mais debaixo do viaduto
fazendo forte não só usar inteiro a
entender o que eu passo o sobre
estaleiro do style estilo livre no
estilo de vida livre que isso trava e
crime
tudo que você vive livre deve evitar que
o show o esquema de corrupção não é meu
parceiro deve entender isso achamos por
bem longe ebserh mestre cerimônia assim
o som eu vi que compartilhava o terceiro
achou olha só vamos mudar esse clima é
teatro mas eu quero gerar um favor pra
cima geral favor pra cima e se exige
tudo é dessa forma que a gente segue
compartilhado dotto obrigado pela sua
atenção disseram que eu disse toque o
seu coração se assim a impressão que
geral já está feliz por isso que eu faço
essa diretriz que disse também estar à
vontade porque eu faço aqui é sem dúvida
boa humildade eu sou ouviu dizer bem
vindo da esquerda a zaga do noroeste seu
parceiro
ficam aqui pra sensações táxi com nossa
vida só satisfaz ou pede seriedade da
sonefe afinal de contas o agente vai e
vem e só teve dez dias 83 me down
microfone está é a minha vez
obrigado a organização que convidou
afinal de conta por nós explicou
eu tô aqui assim mas também estou na rua
porque eu sou jovem cabuloso toda acusa
todas as luzes e vi nenhuma atuação aí o
deixa a nova expressão boneca a little
pill que está na atividade pra mim essa
é uma inspiração criatividade na questão
de idade por sexo esse tipo de
preconceito não tem nexo
jabu versão podem irmãos está com vocês
aqui que eu possa desfaçam